The Joe Rogan Experience speaking of
that they've just released all those
documents JFK documents anything come
out of that did something come out of
that oh one thing that come out was the
they were saying that uh Lee Harvey
Oswald was a Russian asset and that he
had been uh honey potted by his wife and
he lived in Russia in the 1950s and they
think that in this I think what Russia
is trying to say in this is that they
were responsible for making Lee Harvey
Oswald try to kill the president there
was so much [ __ ] going on with that
story for anybody that thinks in 2022
that you know what happened in 1963
you're crazy what does it say what does
Tucker Carlson say
what does he say they spoke with someone
who let's play it so we can hear it
seven minutes long it's long oh I don't
think just let me hear a little bit of
it
it's 10 less than 48 hours later that
lone gunman is himself murdered by
another lone gunman
what are the odds of that
it's one thing if you get struck by
lightning rare but possible but if every
member of your family also gets struck
by lightning all on different days you
might begin to suspect these are not
entirely natural events
but oh replied the US government they
are this bizarre chain of killings was
all entirely natural
so less than a year after the JFK
assassination the Johnson White House
released something called the Warren
Commission report and the report
concluded that while their motives
remained unclear both Lee Oswald and
Jack Ruby had acted alone no one helped
them there was no conspiracy of any kind
Case Closed time to move on and many
many Americans did move on at the time
they had no idea how shoddy and corrupt
the Warren Commission was it would be
nearly 50 years before the CIA admitted
under duress that infected withheld
information from investigators about its
relationship with Lee Harvey Oswald
but even then at the time before that
was known the government's explanation
didn't seem entirely plausible and some
people started asking obvious questions
about it
it was at that point As Americans
started to doubt the official story that
the term conspiracy theory entered our
lexicon as Professor Lance dehaven Smith
points out in his book on the subject
the term conspiracy theory did not exist
as a phrase in everyday American
conversation before 1964. in 1964 the
year the Warren Commission issued its
report the New York Times published five
stories in which conspiracy theory
appeared
now today of course the term conspiracy
theory appears in pretty much every New
York Times story about American politics
it's wielded now as then as a weapon
against anyone who asks questions the
government doesn't feel like answering
but despite 60 years of name calling
those questions have not disappeared in
fact they have multiplied with time and
here's one of them in April of 1964 a
psychiatrist called Louis Joyland West
visited Jack Ruby in his isolation cells
according to West's written assessment
he found that Jack Ruby was quote
technically insane and in need of
immediate psychiatric hospitalization
those are conclusions that pausingly no
one who had spoken to Jack Ruby
previously had reached Ruby had seemed
perfectly sane to the people who knew
him Lewis Joyland West pronounced him
crazy
but what what Wes did not say was that
he was working for the CIA at the time
Lewis Joyland West was a contract
psychiatrist for the spy agency he was
also an expert on mind control and a
prominent player in the now Infamous MK
Ultra program in which the CIA gave
powerful psychiatric drugs to Americans
without their knowledge
so of all the psychiatrists in the world
what in the world was this guy doing in
Jack Ruby's prison cell
the media did not seem interested in
finding out in fact the New York Times
in an extensive 1999 obituary of West
never mentioned the fact that he had
worked for the CIA much less his time in
Jack Ruby's cell
which seems relevant
so you can see why non-crazy people
would wonder about what really happened
and of course many have wondered in 1976
long forgotten the House of
Representatives impaneled a special
committee to reinvestigate the JFK
assassination their bipartisan
conclusion
Jack Kennedy was almost certainly
murdered as the result of a conspiracy
but the question is a conspiracy by whom
well the obvious suspect would be the
CIA
why else would the agency withhold
critical evidence from investigators
is there a benign explanation for that
for maintaining this level of secrecy
for this many years not that we're aware
of and it is illegal in 1992 Congress
passed the President John F Kennedy
assassination records collection act
that act mandated full disclosure of all
documents by 2017 54 years after JFK was
killed
the last Administration promised to
comply fully with that law but under
intense pressure from CI director Mike
Pompeo withheld in the end thousands of
pages of CIA documents
today this afternoon the bite
Administration did exactly the same
thing that would be thousands of pages
of documents after nearly 60 years
after the death of every single person
involved but we still can't see them
clearly it's not to protect any person
they're all dead
is to protect an institution but why
well today we decided to find out
we spoke to someone who had access to
these still hidden CAA documents a
person was deeply familiar with what
they contain
we asked this person directly did the
CIA have a hand in the murder of John F
Kennedy an American president and here's
the reply we received verbatim quote the
answer is yes
I believe they were involved it's a
whole different country from what we
thought it was it's all fake
cases it's hard to imagine a more
jarring response than that again this is
not a quote conspiracy theorist that we
spoke to not even close this is someone
with direct knowledge of the information
that once again is being withheld from
the American public and the answer we
received was unequivocal yes the CIA was
involved in the assassination of the
president wow
bro
wow Jesus Christ
yeah
like 97 of the documents they said have
now been released I think that as of
this to like whatever yesterday or
something and people are starting to
look through those they don't expect to
find anything in those because they're
still you know they've kept all kinds of
documents oh I would definitely not let
people read the ones that would be
looking bad I mean that's the only
explanation why can't we read them they
must be bad they can't be good well they
say a lot of great things about the CIA
we're pretty humble I mean we don't want
that that's going to cause chaos that's
why the whole place of the country's
gonna [ __ ] riot how would they ever
find out if they're able to keep [ __ ]
from us how will they ever find out even
though there's been laws passed and you
know
rulings that they're supposed to release
it in 2017 like
what but why not like what are you doing
what's happening